Hi my name is Ryan Harriss and in 2018 I directed,
produced and co-wrote my first feature film
called ZOOEY.
ZOOEY is a low-budget to no-budget feature
about a young boy who over the course of a
summer escapes from his abusive stepfather
and goes to stay in this kind of janky motel.
It’s at this motel that he meets a young
girl named Zooey who is traveling through
with her brother.
Noah has formed this sort of bond and over
the course of their time together Noah discovers
a secret about her that changes the course
of their summer entirely.
ZOOEY started principal photography in 2018
and it took about nine months to shoot the
entire film due to the fact that we had to
shoot only on weekends because most of the
crew and most of our people were working 9-to-5
jobs including myself.
We also had to fly in our main actor from
another state each time when we were shooting.
So it kind of gave us where we would shoot
for the weekend and then that week I would
sit there and work and figure out what we
were going to shoot the next following weekend.
During this process my team and I learned
so much about everything that we did wrong
and everything that we did right and I wanted
to share with you three ways to understanding
your crew on a low-budget to no-budget feature
film.
Number 1) Your crew wants to know.
On ZOOEY we had about 10-15 people on set
a day and sometimes we had less than that.
Sometimes we had 4 to 5.
Sometimes it was just my DP and I going out
with our talent and shooting due to people’s
availability because we were only shooting
on weekends.
We had about 4 1st AC’s and 4 2nd AC’s
[a focus puller or first assistant camera]
that were on sort of a rotation.
So some people were there on day one through
three.
Other people were there on day 20, other people
were there mid-way through the shoot.
I really wanted to make it a point that whoever
was there on that day understood what we were
trying to achieve that day.
Not just technically but emotionally.
Really know that your crew wants to know and
there is no such thing as oversharing or giving
too much information to your crew because
ultimately they are there to make it better.
Number 2) is your crew is just as creative
as everybody else on set.
With ZOOEY in particular we wanted to make
sure that because we were bring in so many
different people and didn’t have a very
conventional way of shooting a film.
We wanted to make sure that the people we
brought in weren’t just technically masterful
at their specific craft but that they were
just fans of movies and they just loved filmmaking
in general and loved storytelling.
We wanted to make it a point that everybody
on set had something that they wanted to say.
A comment about how a shot was or we used
to gather people around the monitors from
boom ops to camera department to grips.
We wanted to bring people in to just look
at it because they are going to see things
that you’re never going to notice.
Number 3) Listen to your crew, really listen
to them.
The thing I noticed on ZOOEY that I learned
pretty quickly was it’s kind of amazing
how your crew that has surrounded you there
is sort of like a fly on the wall.
They see everything that happens, they see
everything that goes on and things that you
don’t even notice or floats right over your
head.
It’s important that if you provide a platform
for them to come safely talk to you that you
really listen to what they have to say because
they are going to point out little things,
little nuances, things you might not notice
or they might come up with ideas that you
realized would have worked so much better.
So really take your time to listen to your
crew when they come to you and they talk about
things because it’s really, really important
and it’s crucial because at the end of the
day filmmaking is a collaborative experience.
So that’s it on Three Ways of Understanding
Your Crew on A Low-Budget to No-Budget Feature
Film.
And if you have time check out ZOOEY on Amazon
Prime this summer.
Thanks!
Question: Which one of these tips helps you
the most?